you've been over visited me i know your
kids yeah
you're is this being passed on yes yes
our two-year-old right now i'll say how
old are you and she goes i'm four and a
half
which is her older sister's four and a
half and i go no you're not you're not
four and a half and then she grabs my
face and goes
fur
that was also kind of a schwarzenegger a
little bit yeah i'm four and a half
father
gotta get out of here out of this the
bombing there
get out come on
you got the bones i need to pull up on
now
i love schwarzenegger as a baby is so
much fun i want to watch doc mcstuffins
then i need my yoghurts come on i threw
up an impedia light
[Applause]
but with the little baby's body in a
diaper yeah but a cigar yeah but it's
like
going get in here come on
we got to go we got to go got to go
state to california
california
look i'm just curious where were you i'm
trying to fix
now you can't no i can't stop
this is yeah gotta do something more
with him as a baby i
don't know if i would have been done but
it's just so no i'm saying what you've
got to like you've got to produce this
you've got to make a cartoon
where he's a baby the only way i want to
see him from now on yeah you're going to
see that billboard while you're
driving down the sunset like
schwarzenegger baby yeah
come on i would watch
every second of that 50 times i was a pa
on arnold schwarzenegger movie called
collateral damage and
um hey all right
no and that was the big line in that
movie was open up the door there's a
bomb in
the there time i met him the first time
i met him
i go uh he comes up to me and he had a
cigar in his mouth and he goes uh what
is jeff and pita
that's his hair and makeup guys and i go
uh i
i don't know i'll find them and he goes
find them show me your leadership
[Applause]
capabilities
love when you hear a storyline because
you know it's exactly true yeah yeah
just like yes show me your leadership
abilities i was like they're right there
there they are they're sitting in little
director chairs
over there oh my god
i'd like to do this for four more hours